when I was a kid Bobby Fischer man Bobby
Fischer he was a big guy everybody was
excited about Bobby Fischer and Bobby
Fischer
wrote a book with dr. Stuart Margolis
I think dr. Stuart Margolis basically
wrote the book and it was Bobby Fischer
teaches jazz and I thought to myself oh
man this is really great Bobby Fischer
teaches chess I'll study what this guy
knows and you know well I'll be world
champion next day so I got this book you
know I'm really really excited and if
the book is very funny because you read
through the book and then you got to
turn it around and read it through the
second time so it wasn't like there's a
page here a page here it's just a page
here then an upside down agent Medina
okay so here it was you know this nice
book 200 plus examples and all it was
was back rank checkmates it was just one
example after another after the whole
book there is nothing else in the book
except one tactic the back rank
checkmate I'm reading this book I'm
sending myself what is this this guy's a
one-trick pony I did all he knows is the
back rank checkmate you know like that's
it you know like wow you know that's how
he does it that's how he beats all of
his opponents he gets them into a
baccarat checkmate me he execute sit you
know like wow how cool is that man I'd
sure like to do that so anyway so that's
going through my mind I doing this
curriculum thing and then it's funny is
like there's two really great examples
of games that would just played and like
the last few days which are examples of
back train checkmate is like ah this is
great okay the more complex and what I'm
about to show you and I'll stagger our
way through it so this is a very typical
situation we're just a rook ending white
is obviously a pawn
and well if it was White's turn white
might make a move like see through your
rookie seven but it's black to move and
of course black besides that hey you
know he he's a pawn down so he takes the
pond yeah exactly what takes yeah there
you go okay wonderful wonderful
wonderful and of course we have it you
know back rank checkmate Wow and all of
its glory there it is I must say by the
way that when the the first time this
pattern was shown to me I was just a
beginner right you know I found it
astonishing because in reality the way I
won and lost because that was just the
way we did it is we just wiped out all
of our opponent's pieces first you know
we took everything off the board and
then if we had anything left then we
would go after the guys King because
that was the way you did it that was the
technique that everybody had so just the
idea that you could check me you know
without wiping all you know like the guy
off well that's pretty remarkable and in
this particular position of course it's
the suffocation the idea that you could
use blacks forces against black and
produce a checkmate well that was just
the kind of an epiphany we go back for a
second and we can understand that in
this position black should play the move
King II King f8 on variation just too
pissed to prevent any background may
threaten the pawn and prevent the rook
from coming to e7 obviously and then the
whole point in the Bobby Fischer book
was that in such positions black could
play a move like g6 and create looked as
creating looked I really like this by
the way this German word look
meanings err so blacks king simply has
air to breathe you can play King g7
against any back rank checkmate so great
so I was just showing this to the
children's class I had actually preface
this position with a less complicated
position and so the idea was to build up
for the children's class and the
curriculum this whole back rank
checkmate idea and so here of course the
mechanics are very clear white would
love to play rook takes the a check rook
takes e8 rook takes EI check mate except
the Queen defends the rook okay so
instantly it comes into our minds that
gosh all we've got to do is get the
Queen out of the way we get the Queen
out of the way we've got our checkmate
everything is ideal how can we attack
blacks Queen Queen be something okay
well well the problem with clean be
something is if we played Queen d1 for
example our second rook wouldn't be able
to checkmate so after Queen takes rook
takes rook picks we wouldn't be it we'll
make that move so of course we have
young lady yes of course
clean that was the other thought clean
defy very good and so now we can win
spectacularly brilliantly after Queen
takes d5 rook takes rook takes rook
takes checkmate wonderful please sign my
score sheet thank you so much okay
black unfortunately he sees the same
thing he also reasons that rook takes
rook check rook takes pardon me rook
takes rook check Queen takes rook takes
Bishop takes he'll be down so he moves
his Queen he plays Queen a
or unfortunately for us this maintains
blacks defense of the eh square ah
that's bad so we got to go again what do
we do what what on earth should white do
all he's got to do is get rid of the
Queen we can get rid of the Queen he's
got that brilliant checkmate staring him
dead in the face so how could white
attack blacks Queen how how young lady
what do you think you prey you're
probably right but you're probably
scared away from the suggesting the
right yes yeah how how could we possibly
attack blacks Queen well unfortunately a
move like rookie for as nice as it is
he will just trade his rook rook takes
e4 rook takes e4 and then he'll move his
queen back to c6 and our opportunity of
a back rank checkmate is lost can you
see it you're the maestro come on baby
just slip it up there Queen to d4 well
that does that does in fact yeah that's
my stock the bishop there that's why I
stuck the bishop there was just to just
to discourage Queen d4 where else could
white move his Queen that would attack
blacks Queen yes yes excellent excellent
excellent Queen to c4 well that's kind
of a visually nice move we always we
always like these moves that put our
Queen on pre but of course you can't
take it I did it's just sort of like a
challenge you know and again we went
brilliantly Queen takes c4 rook takes
rook takes rook or rook takes e4 and
again rook takes e8
take CA rook takes ei and we have our
Czech mating pattern yay
Queen d7 precisely Queen d7 so black
irritatingly enough annoying opponent
you know goes back with his queen
doesn't allow is a brilliant mate but
what do we do now yes yes Queen take c8
that would be wonderful
especially if black was to cooperate
Queen take c8 Queen take c8 rook takes
e8 rook takes a triptych checkmate
but Queen takes e8 runs into this very
nasty rook takes e8 and there's no more
checkmate on the back lane darn darn
hate that hate that so where else could
whites Queen attack blacks Queen if we
if we go Queen to d5 Queen to a4 it's a
repetition we haven't made any progress
queer Thank You maestro Queen Oh Queen
to g4 oh that's nasty now Queen takes g4
rook takes e8 rook takes a groat xe8 is
our checkmate and at the same time we're
having the threat of Queen takes g7
checkmate oh so now so in a sense we're
going to go back just a moment in a
sense from this starting position with
the Queen on b3 white made the illegal
move white played Queen on b3 to g4 it's
his turn and he made that move how did
he do it he went Queen to d5 Queen to c4
Queen a for Queen C for
Queen to g4 hey hey that's not right
that's not in the rule look and this is
this is a position to the back rank
checkmate Nigel short just played in and
won the Canadian Open wonderful and in
one of his games and I went through the
database unfortunately like a hundred
games in that database I couldn't fish
out that one game that Nigel plate he
had a back ranked checkmate that was
very visual I liked it and I thinking to
myself okay that goes into the
curriculum under the tactics and so in
our efforts to give you the entire
picture a holistic understanding of
chess we'll go through a game that is
currently that was currently that was
played in the tournament that is
currently underway easy for me to say in
Dortmund Germany this is a top top top
top grandmaster tournament and two of
the players are gorg mayer george mayer
jörg he's going to Webster College he's
a 2700 German national and he is playing
I'm going to put a flat Amer Kramnik who
has the black pieces in this particular
game on the bottom because Vladimir won
the game by using this Bobby Fischer's
technique man what else can I call it
but the back rank made it wins every
time every time so welcome welcome
welcome
ok here we go ready so this is a really
boring game by the way this turned out
to be what is called a Catalan a Catalan
variation which it features white V and
shadowing of course in this moment we
have a queen's gambit declined and
everybody and his brother plays moves
like Bishop g5 and Knight c3 for white
but ok we have a Catalan g3
ok Bishop e7 Bishop g2 castles castle
so this is still one of the the most
typical setups of the Catalan now here
black has a choice normally speaking he
captures this pawn and that's the open
variation of the Catalan when black
makes a decision to capture this pawn
notice that that does open up the
diagonal for the bishop so another
choice that black often plays is the
move c7 c6 this is known as ready for
this
their colors cattle and it I mean you
know chess players are as scientific and
precise so in the close cattle and the
idea from blacks point of view is to
keep this pawn on d5 rock-solid so that
this Bishop never has a good point of
view but that wasn't Vladimir's choice
Vladimir captured the pump so white
decides that quite properly he'd like to
recapture his pawn and he plays a move
Queen c2 again this variation has been
played to death there has been hundreds
if not thousands of games that continued
as follows a seven a six a cute little
move if we go back to a moment in this
position we could say that blacks bishop
on c8 this kind of passive it's not
doing anything and it really needs to
get into the battle soon especially in
view of the fact that Queen takes c4 is
on White's agenda so white black plays
this cute little move a seven a six and
his idea is he wants to support his pawn
on c4 with a move b5 but of course it's
white to move and white captures the
pawn Queen takes e4 b5 anyway attacking
the Queen the Queen retreats Queen c2
and Bishop e7 so this is black's big
idea
and a very fine idea it is the bishop on
b7 counters the bishop on g2 and if
black is able to play and move light 97
followed by c5 the position will be even
equal we say so blood so White's idea is
primarily in this variation of the open
Catalan White's idea is to stop black
from advancing his pawn to c5 the most
popular move today is this move Bishop
d2 and this really looks like a modest
move and in many ways it is a very
modest move but it has several ideas
behind it the first idea is that if
black plays c5 prematurely white will
capture the pawn on c5 and then play the
move b4 to protect a pawn on c5 that's
the first idea of white the second idea
of white is he wants to bring his rook
to c1 to pressure this pawn on c7 and
finally the last idea of white is if
black makes the natural move Knight to
d7 in order to play c5 on his very next
turn white has a very subtle and
peculiar idea he plays Bishop a5 not
only does this bishop now attack the
pawn on c7 but it also pins the pawn the
pawn on c7 can't move because the Queen
on d8 would be captured so that's a very
subtle idea for white Bishop d2 and now
we get this incredible move rook a7 what
on earth is that okay I know it's a it's
a little bit complex but the idea is is
black is expecting white to play the
move rook c7 rook c1 I beg your pardon
attacking the pawn on c7 so would this
move rook to a7 which really looks like
a stupid move
but we've got to give Latimer kramnik
some credit and actually the idea of the
move rook a7 is to protect the pawn on
c7 and to be able to move the bishop
here so he Latimer wants to meet the
move rook c1 as follows Brooke c1 bishop
efore and presto our pawn is protected
secondly this move rook a7 is a kind of
a waiting move it's asking white what he
wants to play if white jumps with Bishop
a5 black has very powerful move knight
c6 simply attacking the bishop and
saying get out of town just go away
so this move rook a 7 is a kind of a
waiting move rook c1 Bishop a4 Queen d1
now again this position has Beach has
been reached numerous times and
everybody everybody and his brother
plays the move Queen b3 ok and as we'll
see I don't like this move Queen d1 at
all now your admirer is a very very
strong Grandmaster so this was
preparation but here's a question for
you can black capture this pawn on d4
can he play Bishop takes f3 Bishop f3
Queen takes d4 first of all the correct
answer is yes because it's legal hey you
guys are just wondering does that hang
something and you're trying to figure
out whether or not it's a blunder or not
but this is why in fact
Kramnik was asked the very same question
and he answered it yes I'll take the
pawn now let's go back just for a second
because I told you a moment ago that
everybody and I mean everybody in this
position that has reached this position
has played the move Queen B 3 now the
difference is is that after Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes in fact now
this would be a very bad move because we
have the skier Bishop e3 attacks the
Queen and oopsy-daisy that rook is about
to be captured once the Queen moved the
rook is lost so black could not capture
the pawn however in the game variation
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
Black said wait a minute
please go ahead please please make my
day play the move Bishop e3
I'll trade Queens and then I'll block
the threat to my rook by playing the
move c5 so I just Graham it said I'll
take the pawn and you show me your
compensation
a4 and kramnik said okay I'll play c7 c6
your turn Queen b3 now so it likes a
very strange impression this novel idea
of Queen d1 and suddenly after and now
we understand why Kramnik played the
move c6
he wanted to bring his rook which looks
pretty goofy on the a7 square and he
centralized and he's basically saying to
white hey listen you're welcome to take
this pawn and my knight will capture
your bishop but I'll be fine
have a good position if you do that
Bishop f4 Knight d5 so these moves were
all played and night before was played
so at the moment it's not really a back
rank checkmate Queen d1 Queen d1 rookies
we already have made lift so we have
kingi to but then our pieces will be
pinned and that will be very unpleasant
for the first player so the rook was
forced to drop back Bishop c5
threatening the pawn on f2 black-white
was not I mean this would be an easy way
III would be an easy way to resolve the
threat of Queen takes f2 but after the
move III is played a few things are a
little bit uncomfortable for for black
let me just show in the game you're
played the best move rook f1 had white
played the move III this was this would
be unpleasant for white after the move
Queen f6 because now thanks to the fact
that this pawn is on three is on III
this Knight has a very nice square 93 if
we take the Bishop rook takes e5 Queen
takes f3 well now we are back
threatening that rook b1 check and that
back rank the back rank for white
becomes an issue
in addition black is threatening this
nasty 93 so we got here oops excuse me
and George play this good move rook f1
takes on a5 takes rook c7 9 c3 Queenie
e5 rook d1 h5 now at this point these
are really two
top grandmasters like who are playing I
mean this position is really even-steven
the most especially because of the
presence of opposite color bishops
nevermind the fact that the pawn
structures are completely equal and
again this position should be a draw and
it's beyond my imagination that any top
Grandmaster would actually lose this
game with white so it was this like a
battle of wills you know mind over
matter or was just a horrible play now
far be it for me from ever ever saying
you know horrible play I played some
horrible game but the simplest way for
white to play in this position would be
the move King g2y because as we'll see
in the game black plane to move h5 which
intimates that black is trying to harass
White's King with this move h4 and white
could meet h5 with h4 and again the
positions
even-steven let's go and see what
actually happened in the game and we'll
see it a very important difference York
played rook d1 and this move is in fact
wrong and after h5 blunt white would
like to play the move h4 but could not
why not why not why not play h4 Queen
takes g3 don't hate that thanks to the
pin of the bishop against the f2 pawn
innit you're trying to take that clean
you want to take that clean but it's
illegal if White's King had been on g2
this would have been no problem
so h5 King g2 is now played and now h4
now black has
some some abilities to needle white a
little bit in the first place you could
play a move like h3 check and in case of
King takes h3 Bishop takes f2 and white
structure has been compromised so but
nothing terrible is going on here mind
you the position still even but just the
fact that White has miss played it a
little bit with rook d1 probably gave
Kramnik reason to maybe want to play on
Knight c5 Knight e4 this also struck me
as a very very strange move I don't I
really quite frankly I didn't understand
that move at all I thought that white
would play a move like rook d7 here and
bring the other rook to d1 so this move
was a strange move for me Bishop came
back to f8 and this was also a strange
move to me rook c1 I didn't understand
this move either if I were white from my
point of view as white player well I
love my pawns man I mean God gave me
eight of them I better lie I better love
my pawns you know the most the most
politic pieces on the board upon so if
we fall in love with your pawns this is
a good thing the pawn on b2 is attacked
defend the pawn on b2 I would have
thought that rook d2 and rook a one D
one every Grandmaster in the world would
play like that and this blunder trade
trade trade thank you very much for the
pun now I don't know if at this moment
jürg thought that he had full
compensation thanks to his active rook
or not but this was a very strange way
for white to play queenie five attacks
the rook queen comes to d7
now how did that does anybody see this
having anything to do with what this
whole lecturer is about which is the
back rank checkmate of course not
there's nothing here even remotely close
to the back rank checkmate Queen f5 okay
this is a good deal good thing he
defends the pawn on on s7d f-- g for
attacking the Queen Queen F for keeping
queen of for g5 yes Queen F for g5 and
now black played the obvious Knight d5
so gift me the rook gift me the rook
white played ooh Knight f6 check who so
the idea is if we take the knight talk
new variation ah hate that checkmate
don't Vladimir Kramnik would lose so
after Knight f6 check what on earth did
Vladimir play what do you think young
lady what do you think if you were black
what would you do you could see
checkmate is in me is staring you in the
face
how could you defend checkmate
it's not easy Ken you're the man you're
the one with the answers yeah we got an
audience that wants to know bravo Bravo
Queen takes f6 yeah yeah after Queen
takes f6 yes but what happens after
Queen takes f6 do you guys see the
background
checkmate now if Y takes the Queen what
do you see what do you think as tell me
okay that's a check I'll just go back
with my king
checkmate a back rank checkmate
maybe that guy Bobby Fischer was on to
something right I mean hey that was a
pretty pretty back rank checkmate and
that's what I was how it related to the
curriculum for the moment and
serendipity of it all after Knight f6
yes one gentleman said could black also
have played Knight takes yes he could in
this case after Knight takes pawn tags
white had blood upon me White has really
good chances to hold the draw to defend
before black was just a pawn up and
winning but that now white has real good
chances of defense so that was why
Knight takes f6 wasn't so good but now
after Queen takes f6 oh my goodness your
threat you you're facing a checkmate a
back ranked checkmate you're also facing
Queen takes g5 pawn with a check so
you're played Queen takes d5 kind of a
funny you know like putting your Queen
but that's the best move unfortunately
for white after playing even the best
move he's still upon behind and
unfortunately for him his King is also
compromised after Queen takes d5
vladimir played queen g6 which white
played Queenie fine and now black has a
really nice move a very nice move if you
had blacks position what move would you
make
Bishop d6 now that move really would
work nicely after Bishop d6 Queen takes
d6 Queen takes g5 check if the King were
to retreat we've got our great
background checkmate unfortunately the
white player would not cooperate we
would play Bishop d6 Queen takes d6
Queen takes g5 and instead of retreating
and walking into a mate you play King h3
like oh I think I just dropped my bishop
okay so we don't drop our bishop instead
we play a real nice move my hint is that
black is a pawn up so now that we know
that how could we take advantage of the
fact that we have an extra pawn yeah
well it's I like to keep them before we
exactly like but can we lever leverage
that pawn to our advantage what could we
do yes sir of course of course
hey we're a pawn up we might as well
utilize it and thanks to this move rook
b5 I am you got to move the Queen and
guess what another pawn is right there
ready for plucking Queen went back to f4
Vladimir played a nasty little move here
he played rook f5 and said hey you know
like where are you going to move your
queen your play Queen efore Queen takes
g5 check King h3 and now and now and now
black is two pawns up he's completely
winning and I must say I do like
Vladimir's technique I've always admired
he has a mix a mixture of styles in some
ways he's
carpeau Vian in some ways he's Petrosyan
and he thinks to himself well I'm two
ponds up so I'm going to win the game
but what could my opponent possibly
threaten in a worst-case scenario the
opponent could play rook here and maybe
Queen here and end up taking my bishop
so Vladimir chase the rook and play g6
so Jay chase the Queen and play g6 so
what's his idea is that whenever push
comes to shove he'll always be able to
drop his Queen back and keep his bishop
protected and it was here in this
position that white resigned so this was
a very nice game and let me just show
let me just before let me just ask how
would white win after Queen takes a six
I want you to think in terms of back
rank checkmates for a moment as well
how could white win by force
what would white sequence of sequence of
moves be
I'll help you out we'll start with a
check we'll start with a check
Queen f5 is a good start
King g2 has to go back and now h3 check
exactly
now here unfortunately white faces a
Hobson's choice
if he goes back how do we check made on
the back rank if white how does he do it
clean the vive King g1 the Queen slides
you notice that the Queen covers this
square and the rook [ __ ] covers this
square is like the Queen goes to be one
and it slides right in between them you
know there's like the guy it with the
ball going up the field and there's no
tacklers came to be one Queen goes here
and it's a back rank checkmate and what
about what happen I I think my computer
so fast I I mean it shows us era how
would black checkmate if White's King
came up King to g3 how could he
checkmate yes young lady do you know the
answer very good very good yes
oops Queen to h4 unfortunately they yeah
we just that just drives the King away
but we do have this one and that's a
checkmate so even though the game really
didn't have so much content that that
that little swing of combina that that
little swing of moves here really caught
my eye I thought that that was very very
attractive so uh and just a Bobby
Fischer's point I probably checkmated a
lot of both comments on the back rank